Gary Marshall the genius creator of
happy gays who passed away on Tuesday
now Henry lost the Fonz of course and
the Fonz his best friend Ritchie was
played by Ron Howard and Ron got a bit
emotional when he opened up to us about
his mentor and his friend Gary Marshall
so in tonight's big picture Gary's happy
day I just want to show you this and get
your thoughts because we thought it was
pretty special I was very proud that all
these young people who came to me the
Arenal 18 19 20 years old have now grown
and furthered their careers as directors
Ron Howard's one of the best directors
in the whole industry he did encourage
us he did that's who he was
that's not him trying to look good on a
television interview that's who he was
and he gave us that gift and created
that environment and you know all of us
who are lucky to have been a part of his
orbit need to take that to heart and try
to do it ourselves
you kind of got me with that one thank
you for thank you for showing me Gary
brilliant guy a funny guy playful but
but a fantastic teacher and mentor Ron
was just 20 years old when he was cast
as Richie Cunningham he later directed
Gary in a small acting role in his own
film directorial debut 1977 s Grand
Theft Auto Gary became one of these
guiding forces not just creatively
because Gary Marshall as successful as
he was whether it was stage big screen
his mantra to anyone who was beginning
to succeed in the bigot in the business
was simply said this is this is great
it's fantastic but don't ever forget
that life is more important than show
business and he lived that and you could
see it demonstrated in the choices he
made Gary Marshall made TV history with
a long list of hits the Odd Couple
Happy Days Laverne and Shirley and even
a far-fetched sitcom about an alien on
earth featuring a larger-than-life
stand-up comic
putting your bones Mork and Mindy
made the late Robin Williams a star but
happy days
always held a special place in Gary's
heart happy days to me was the show
where the cast had the best chemistry on
and off the stage and off the stage was
really a pleasure to be with these
people family and you know personal
integrity with people these things were
present with him it's a heartbreaking
loss